senator Gravelle one of the things I
wanted to touch on is something that
when I announced on Twitter that we
would be interviewing you a lot of
people said you need to ask Mike
Gravelle about this and it's your
position on 9/11 I've not I've
researched it a little bit there are
those who characterize you as a
so-called 9/11 truther someone who
believes that 9/11 was an inside job I I
prefer to just go to the source and ask
you what you think what is your position
on 9/11 well I'm glad you raised it
because most people who accuse me or
others of being truthers or conspiracy
nuts
they're just not knowledgeable about
what's happened with respect to 9/11
here if you just follow the sequence
George Bush did not want to have a
commission it was forced on him by the
widows of those who died in the in the
course of the attack to when he when
they decided they were going to have a
commission Henry Kissinger of all
persons was floated as the person who
chaired this this commission now you
talk about a person's who's got the art
of covering the backside it's Henry
and so now that didn't that didn't float
very well so they picked up two other
two other members of the political
community who were reasonable at good
reputations because they had good
reputations but even the key members on
the committee said that they did not do
a good job so now we we get today that
what did the committee produce the
Commission
well first off and this is what makes
you suspicious who they said no mention
was mentioned in the Commission about
building seven building seven came down
at 5:30 on the same day as the others
came down in the morning the Twin Towers
and building 7 had never been hit by an
airplane there are modest fires but the
person who owned the lease on the twin
towers also owned building 7 and he then
gave the order to bring the building
down if you look at the way the building
came down you'll see that it was a
controlled demolition no question about
that
and so now you see art architects and
engineers thousands coming out and
saying that hey this element didn't fit
and then the testimony can have a people
hearing pop up as the floors came down
in the twin towers indicating that here
too this was interior controlled
demolition okay so let me just let me
pause here for a second if I can
senator develop they love it because I
we I don't know that we have the ability
nor scope to fully adjudicate every
claim that's been made here but with
regard to building seven I don't know if
you've seen the the series of
Engineering reports and investigations
about building seven and everything
you've said without being an engineer
myself has a counterpoint from engineers
there's a very extensive Popular
Mechanics investigation into the
particulars of building seven and I'm
not adjudicating it personally but what
I want to make clear is I want to make
sure you're aware that every claim
you've made has been significantly
refuted by engineers and I don't know if
you've seen the Popular Mechanics report
yes yes I have and I think is ridiculous
okay and and so but here too if if
everything is so great and you had a
faulty Commission here we had three
Commission's that studied the
assassination of John Kennedy why can't
we have another Commission to study what
really happened at 9/11 do not depend
upon a an inserter article in Popular
Mechanics
so you're saying by it's just to be
clear by inserted you mean that it's
sort of a piece of propaganda that was
that was crowbarred in there
create when you take a point-by-point it
just doesn't measure up to the
scientific the volunteer scientific
community to study 911 but wouldn't
someone who volunteers wouldn't wouldn't
the people most likely to volunteer to
do this stuff for free be people who are
there not because they have the most
expertise but because they have the most
incentive to say here's something I want
to go and do for free like I don't know
that the fact that they're volunteers
helps the case well when you have
engineers architects and physicists who
come up with alternative scenarios that
are promulgated by this article in in
Popular Mechanics but let me point out
another thing if you're not persuaded by
that what about follow the bunny you
know if you if you have a suspicion of
something you can say well maybe I ever
follow the money and see where it leads
well where did the money go after the
9/11 it went to the military-industrial
complex and so maybe there's an
involvement buddy well listen I mean
these are like I think here's the
problem I have with this senator a
Revell that you know the
military-industrial complex has been fed
in a variety of ways dating all the way
back to you know the post-world War two
ERA or wherever you you first sort of
want to start measuring and there's no
question that the 9/11 attacks were used
by the Bush administration to justify a
war in Iraq the George W Bush clearly
wanted regardless and it was sort of
convenient to use 9/11 as a scapegoat
but individually you know when we when
we take one by one the claims that
you're making the engineering stuff for
example most the overwhelming number of
engineers that have looked at this don't
agree with you so aren't you being
selective and capricious by saying well
I think all the engineers other than the
ones that agree with me are plants for
example or they've crowbar
false reports into Popular Mechanics I
think that you know if we were to apply
the same sort of standard to climate
change you would end up as a climate
change denier if you applied the same
standards that you're applying here in
quite the country but they say no yeah
David you're making a case that all the
rest of the engineers in the world are
against what the engineers that have
looked at this have suspicions no I'm
not saying all what I'm saying is the
consensus of the majority is still that
we know what incentive building seven
listen there's no consensus what's been
fabricated by the mainstream media is
that the people who are suspicious
the work is suspicious yeah of something
bad happening that what's impossible
that American would be involved with
killing 3,000 Americans in this
situation
well impossible my god Cheney is
responsible for thousands and thousands
of deaths along with George Bush so it's
not impossible
yeah but Senators Ravel so I think we so
okay wait hold on a second let me very
important I do too I do too but here's
the point I want to make senator
Gravelle and I was I want you to react
when I make when I say it's an inside
job I don't know who the insiders are
that's fair I don't know and I'm glad
that you're telling me what you think I
mean I'm glad that your talent yeah I'm
not putting the words in your mouth I'm
just simply listening to what you're
asserting good well here if you have a
situation where we've been able to
declare war on terror we mean it's an
infinite war forever and and so how do
we get to that point when you had the
neocons writing a letter to clinton
suggesting that what we need is a and an
excuse something like Pearl Harbor to to
generate the interest in the American
public to fight these wars and and of
course Osama bin Laden is over there in
Afghan
and so we have to go to the Middle East
in attack attack Hussein who had no hand
at all I get that I get that but here's
the thing senator Gravelle here's your's
the two things I want to say and then we
should start to kind of wind down number
one you know you said why would it be so
shocking that the government might have
some involvement in 9/11 and the killing
of 3,000 Americans when Bush Cheney you
know they make decisions and people die
all the time there's a difference
between the reality that when you're the
president of a country like the United
States your foreign policy decisions
lead to people dying the decisions lead
to civilians dying the decisions lead to
members of the military dying that is
not proof that the Bush administration
would have a hand or be likely to have a
hand in 9/11 foreign policy leads to
people dying absolutely but that doesn't
tell us that they would be involved in
the 9/11 attacks well well what you have
to do is is respond to what we're really
talking about is we want a new study we
want a new Commission to look at this
and it shouldn't be involving I'd say a
commission that would have the last
street heads of the United Nations
should be on this commission okay if you
just put politicians on a commission and
their and their assistants in the
scientific community you're gonna get
what you've been getting
I agree that there should be more than
Ayers politicians I agree when cross you
get one point across why is it that the
American media which I maintain his
control lock stock and barrel Biden
military-industrial complex why is that
American media circles the wagons and
doesn't want a study an additional
Commission which a media outlet but
someone horked Commission to find out
why 3,000 Americans died to set up the
stage for infinite wars which
media outlets have come out and said
they don't want any more investigation
well when's the last time you heard
about anybody talking about an
additional investigate okay but hold on
a second there's a difference between
corporate media isn't ringing bells
saying we need another investigation you
asserted that corporate media is against
another investigation I've not heard
that from anybody can you name any one
in corporate about anybody talking about
a commission when you have thousands of
architects and engineers that call for
another Commission no no if who else can
call for a commission after looking at
the facts
what would Kelvin seal senators Ravel
yes what would you see what would
convince you that the government was not
involved in the line 9/11 attacks what
would you need to see government was
involved or not involved I think from my
point of view in reading this very
carefully and studying a lot of the
reports that came out including the
official government report and the
article in Popular Mechanics that right
now there's a consensus in American
public nurtured by the
military-industrial complex and
mainstream media but there's no need to
have another Commission study I just
come back again let me repeat there were
three studies three Commission's on Jack
Kennedy's assassination could we not
have another Commission to look at what
really happened on 9/11 that's a
question all right what do you want to
have the Commission to look into this
technically so so if I so - now to
circle back your position is not that
you believe the government was involved
in 9/11 it's that so far you're not
satisfied that any investigation has
disproven it senator
yeah accurate yes okay you're quite
right my position hasn't changed
got it I still use the terminology
inside job who is on the inside I don't
know but a commission
could help probably discover what that
is right now all we do is say these are
a group of Saudis that the young Saudis
that were out there doing their thing to
to damage America
well these this group of Saudis
interestingly enough had a lot of help
from somebody from somebody I don't know
it's I don't say it's the vice president
but I do they had help from somebody
when you get a situation where from two
different across the continent FBI
offices that report that the the Saudis
are taking training on how to fly large
airplanes they don't want to know how to
land them just what no these it this is
at the mid-level of the FBI at the top
level they can't even put the dots
together that existed at the at the
middle level does not give you pause to
begin to question what's going on all
right I think that we sort of better
understand the perspective and you know
inside job has been clarified and
expanded upon and I think it's always
best to go right to the source rather
than just go by what's written about you
a senator lavalle so I appreciate you
clarifying all of this for us thank you
thank you ask that question because I
first off I don't get asked that
question very much because mainstream
media does not want to cover this issue
I'm glad to cover it and clearly my
audience will see that we are on
different sides of it but I have no
problem talking about it we've been
speaking with former US Senator Mike
Gravel he is running for president in
2020 senator I really appreciate your
time today thank you for having me